[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
breakfast eat my baby for dinner
had to switch up the methods we don't
hang with pretenders i'm the five four
three two
one save the city yet again here it
comes
vigilante on the rise why is it
surprising they throw agents at your boy
to keep the fix divided
frequent flyer and i always preach to
fly united [ __ ] be so scared to fail
that's why they keep it quiet
god flow i know you hear a rocket
pioneer gave me the wheel then a [ __ ]
had the power steering
steady faking what you making ain't
what's up guys just dropped my baby off
at r1 motorsport
to get wrapped uh it came from the
factory in miami blue
i just need to change it up i got prom
so that's why i tune it even though i
probably shouldn't
as tom seguro says don't touch it um
yeah
something different instead of getting a
new car i just change the color it's
that easy
i'm here at the best with r1 motorsport
you can tell all the crazy cars that we
got there
too many lamborghinis for my liking but
he specializes in porsches so hopefully
it goes well
it will it'll go well gave me the wheel
then a [ __ ] had the power steering
steady faking what you making ain't no
power near it i bet this on your
radio as soon as power hear it yeah i
wear my cape real loosely zoning two
three i'm getting new cheese bruh
cowabunga on a routine that's a true
thing routine i made a new scene
it could be a short life not a long one
where you coming from where i'm from
we got going on today b get out my baby
picking up my baby
car is done the car the transformation
is
[Music]
you never done i've been had the vision
martin luther me dreaming about the
rituals
i'ma need the rings i'ma go to distance
do it for my team
[ __ ] it's my religion yo girl is some
christian she ain't even christian
they all want a bad boy when they see
the piston
i'm all in my feelings i might need a
minion i might have to pivot i might
need a digit
from decisions from decision [ __ ]
think he's stupid they be [ __ ]
tripping
hit him with precision
[Music]
it could be a short life not a long one
when you coming from where i'm from
[Music]
oh tonight you mean tonight we got two
sold out shows
two of the four sold out shows at the
haha here a little local gig
if you catch my drift literally right
before the mandate hits
so this is the last show without mask
[Music]
well ain't she just feeling the life
when a rock star step in the building
tonight
everybody want to call me to villani
just as long as they willing to fight
man i ain't got nothing to prove i'm
chilling i'm nice
that boy in that cold just chilling in
ice and i ain't gotta ask if you feeling
the real
but i do it for life do it for love you
are now turned into a beautiful drug
[Music]
god
[ __ ] bars
[Music]
right we wouldn't complain if there's a
big ass game right all right dude that's
great
how gay am i first question is a big day
was it circumcised
she was done too she
[Laughter]
you deserve to get popped off on imma
pop off on you no matter [ __ ] what
[Music]
up
wake up to yourself and see the signs
destiny is peaking through the blinds
[Music]
reaching to
you got to yourself the creators of that
right a little bit yeah
but at the time i didn't watch it oh
right
so yeah i thought yeah and you were like
whatever
i dude you're not playing with geniuses
my whole bit was
when someone talked about game of
thrones like there's dragons in it right
they're like yeah like grown man all
right
i remember that now i'm obsessed with it
it was such a shame i missed the
opportunity to talk
because he was on a private jet with
these [ __ ] people i thought they were
you weren't yeah i thought they were
writers for always sunny and i go you
guys write for always sunday i was like
the new season they're like what
like what do you do they wrote game of
thrones was like
lame and they just didn't talk like i
said
did you ask him questions you're like
nah i was like oh god that's so smart
those people
how many seasons does that show eight
but they get so
into the books so you know they're books
before nice or something
they were on script for like the first
five
seasons like five and a half after five
and a half they go off script and they
do it themselves
and it's not as good
for it but the first five are [ __ ]
fire i don't mind six
the network was probably like we want
more seasons the red wedding
insane dude she sees the chain mail
under his thing
she's all [ __ ] no no
it's better than the second time i'm
going to start rank chain now
i'm getting into the night fights is
that what you're gonna do i don't give a
[ __ ] did what
would you do you only watch you didn't
you didn't get into any shows really
just
you know me dog you got nothing to do i
know
so you know i i literally had and i
thought about it too
i literally had every opportunity to
watch to get into
something did you see game of thrones
have you ever seen it no i've never seen
it
that is like my life story you haven't
never seen any favorite moment
in game of thrones when you think again
is there an image or a scene that comes
to mind
winter's coming i know that part that
part's [ __ ] great that's all i know
there's so many one minutes like the
when i realized it was a great show
when when uh the mother of dragons uh
whatever her name is
that remember that the uh um the guy who
had the legion of
soldiers that would do anything where he
cuts the guy's nipple off and he doesn't
oh it's when they're speaking the the
native tongue yeah and she does this
and she doesn't know he's trying to hold
that dragon the baby dragon
and she says that's a dragon and he is
not used to being take that
he's not born to take orders from a
tyrant like you
and she just goes she says that says
that and that thing just goes
because he's trying to hold on it was
like and she did give him the command
just goes
things please don't do that it comes
with the man it's and it's never caught
on
no it's caught on people
i haven't made any merch yet but if you
guys guys thanks for the overwhelming
request for merch man dragon merch over
when we request
guys it's coming you know when something
doesn't work and you keep running that
play
that's brian is live dude i never brian
i never get in a car on the street where
i'm not inundated with man dragon
and [ __ ] man drinking thanks a lot
you guys appreciate it give us one i'm
like
guys please
they're like oh what the [ __ ] that's
amazing it just doesn't yeah
i'm saying i i agree but i'm saying the
fans freak out when i say man dragon i
just wish it worked
it does dude stop f i stop
poo pooing my nickname that was given to
me by the people it's not cool they're
not gonna be happy
i can't believe about all the scenes
you know there's that learn that
language
[Music]
are these real languages no just
languages
that's somebody's kid so it's a pretty
dope scene yeah it's a [ __ ] joke
that was so off he's like don't remember
she's like that dragon
does not like masters and then the
dragon was all good and then he was like
you mean cat who knows i don't know
my
there's i was doing this
and he was just holding it like this i
got the gist of it though brian i got to
just
yeah yeah it didn't get you right like
the from it it looks dope though
oh